bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro de ski mag quels
sont les grands projets pour 2019 sur
saint quentin en yvelines
trois priorités se dessine le
développement économique la mobilité et
le logement
le territoire paris sur l'innovation
pour répondre aux besoins des habitants
et des entreprises
les grands projets pour 2019 on fait
tous ces partis
[Musique]
une nouvelle année se profile nous
sommes donc allés vers les saint
quentinois pour leur demander ce qu'ils
souhaiteraient pour leur quotidien
un grand magasin attrape une fiabilité
plus importante au niveau des transports
nouveaux logements il ya beaucoup de
problèmes à beaucoup beaucoup parce que
si les vieux appartements qui seront
créés en temps logement social aussi
peut-être mieux adaptée je pense que
c'est à dire une banlieue plutôt
sympathique au niveau des offres
d'emploi l'ag magna qui compose plus de
logements tous ceux qui en cherchent
excusez là où il ya le présent pas ça
c'est pour les souhaits mais nous nous
sommes aussi intéressés au projet à
l'oeuvre sur les douze communes du
territoire
la priorité c'est le développement
économique à saint quentin en yvelines
monlat indiscutablement on a de très
bons résultats et c'est rassurant dans
cette période où on nous diminue les
moyens publics
heureusement que les entreprises sont là
travaillent bien automobile aérospatiale
banque et finance énergie santé dix sept
mille entreprises sont implantées sur le
territoire saint quentinois
une présence qui permet de comptabiliser
145 mille emplois pour conserver ces
acteurs économiques et en attirer
d'autres l'agglomération souhaite rester
attractive certains immeubles sont en
cours de rénovation
quand d'autres sont reconstruits deux
cent cinquante mille mètres carrés sont
aussi en cours de développement
parc de bureaux espaces de coworking
centre de recherche et développement la
reconstruction de l'anneau rouge sur le
parvis de la gare de saint quentin en
yvelines est également envisagée le but
implanter une nouvelle structure en
adéquation avec les nouveaux usages
une autre réflexion est lancée afin de
créer un parc d'affaires high tech avec
les grands groupes mais aussi avec les
tpe pme innovantes
le pôle sera développé sur les communes
d'elancourt plaisir trappe et les
clayes-sous-bois commerce services offre
culturelle et sportive sont autant
d'atouts pour attirer les entreprises
mais pas seulement vous avez les
transports qui sont une
condition aussi de deux pour augmenter
la compétitivité de nos entreprises faut
encore améliorer les transports
autre impératif la formation qui ouvrira
les portes aux emplois de demain
rassemble deux communes se sont
appropriés cela de transformer
complètement leur école leur pédagogie
la formation des profs les contenus une
pédagogie et des contenus qui passe par
l'utilisation et l'appropriation des
outils numériques dès le plus jeune âge
toute notre société va évoluer avec avec
le numérique puisque dans les années à
venir
c'est près de 80% de nos métiers qui
vont se transformer ou être totalement
touché par par le numérique c'est pour
ça qu'il faut que dès la plus jeune
enfance dès que cela est possible que
l'on soit familiariser avec cette notion
de numérique
c'est un départ qui nous paraît très
important
et en plus en terme d'égalité des
chances pour tous les tous les enfants
et les futurs étudiants dès le primaire
donc c'est s'étend sur de plus en plus
sur les douze communes après c'est les
collèges c'est les lycées et puis c'est
la première université française
que va devenir paris saclay qui comme
une bonne une bonne nouvelle pour tous
les saint quentinois parce que plus tôt
dans leurs enfants vous ça coûte cher
leurs billets très loin des universités
à l'étranger ça coûte une fortune balle
à idron une des meilleures universités
quand même au monde qui sera donc
accessible l'objectif de l'agglomération
est d'augmenter de 30% la réussite
scolaire des jeunes saint quentinois les
entreprises nous demandent de plus en
plus d'avoir augmenter l'employabilité
des jeunes qui sortent de saint quentin
et des moins jeunes
dix mille offres d'emploi restent à
pourvoir dans le secteur du numérique
sur l'agglomération pour répondre à la
demande des entreprises saint quentin en
yvelines a lancé en 2018
son label école et campus du numérique
cet organisme dispense ses cours de
niveau bac à bac +2 à travers un panel
de treize formations intensives les
stagiaires peuvent ainsi se former au
métier de développeur web programmeurs
et autres professions du numérique
autres formations absolument nécessaire
qui touche le numérique cela concerne la
cybersécurité donc il est une dérive et
de du numérique
à terme l'objectif est de former 300
personnes par an le dispositif devrait
être élargi aux niveaux 1 2 bac + 3 à
bac +5 avec des formations développées
par l'estaca et l'université versailles
saint quentin en yvelines
mais le développement économique ne va
pas de soi sans un maillage pertinent
des modes de transports l'aménagement de
pôle gare de transport collectif en site
propre le développement des circulations
douces ou des transports novateur vont
être impulsé en 2019
[Musique]
même si 50 à être est une commune très
bien doté en mode de transport il faut
toujours donc améliorer les différents
modes de transport puisque ont à peu
près à 70% des personnes qui viennent de
lexique viennent de l'extérieur de 50 ha
pour travailler dans 50 ha dont qui
prennent quotidiennement les transports
l'évolution de la mobilité va
s'articuler autour de trois axes le
premier l'aménagement de paul gars comme
ici à la verrière cofinancé à hauteur de
16 millions d'euros par ile-de-france
mobilité le département et
l'agglomération
le projet devrait développer une
intermodalité plus performantes
le but permettre à tous de combiner les
modes de déplacement la construction
d'un parc relais de 750 places démarrera
en tout début d'année
une capacité qui se veut évolutive ce
parking sur quatre ou cinq niveaux
pourra accueillir un étage
supplémentaire si besoin
c'est vraiment un projet extrêmement
ambitieux avec également des créations
de passage pour les piétons pour les
vélos des meilleurs accès et bien sûr
tout ce qui est fonction d'
fonctionnement au niveau des bus pour le
covoiturage pour les taxis deux autres
contrats de pôles seront développés en
l'un à la gare de plaisir grignon avec
la rénovation complète de ses abords
voirie carrefour d'accès stationnement
piste piétonne et cyclable
l'autre à la gare de villes pro des
claies ici un aménagement paysager verra
le jour sur le parvis et la
multimodalité sera développé autre
projet celui de la future gare de
saint-quentin est à guyancourt
celles ci pourraient à l'avenir
accueillir la ligne 18 du métro du grand
paris express
actuellement en discussion maillage des
voies de circulation et intermodalité
sont à l'étude
c'est pôle gare devrait à terme inciter
les habitants à moins prendre leur
voiture
mais pas seulement parce qu'on a aussi
un plan vélo avec des vélostations oui à
celle de 50 ans mais la verrière va être
équipée également d'une d'une
vélostation donc nous en avons fait
également sur la gare de plaisir grignon
également et les clès voit également la
demande
d'autres travaux colossaux se poursuivre
le développement du transport collectif
en site propre
depuis la gare de la verrière jusqu'à la
gare de trappes le doublement du pont
guy schuller et l'aménagement du
carrefour de la malle me donne à mon
repas le tout pour fluidifier la
circulation sur cet axe
tout comme le doublement du pont de la
villedieu à elancourt certains travaux
se poursuivent
d'autres commencent c'est le cas de
l'enfouissement de la rn10 et de
l'aménagement du plateau urbain attrape
à terme un plateau urbain de 400 mètres
face à l'hôtel de ville verra le jour
ainsi que deux ronds-points en entrée et
sortie de ville le tout afin de
réunifier les quartiers nord et le
centre ville de trappes actuellement
coupée en deux par un flux quotidien de
80 mille véhicules
[Musique]
400 km d'itinéraires cyclades dont 150
dédié au vélo
la bicyclette et rennes à saint quentin
en yvelines en 2018 les pistes ont été
rénovés sur plus d'un kilomètre et de
nouvelles pistes ou vu le jour sur plus
de 5 km l'objectif est de pouvoir aussi
associer les cinq communes nouvelles
pour la mise en place de pistes
cyclables avec des objectifs de décide
d'avoir des liaisons entre eux entre les
villes de relier l'ensemble des douze
communes avec un réseau plus important
de pistes cyclables
l'offre de location de vélos devraient
être élargies le 14 décembre dernier la
vélostation de la gare de saint quentin
en yvelines a fêté sa première année
d'existence
cent soixante dix vélos classiques
pliant ou électriques sont en location
courte ou longue durée
230 places de stationnement sécurisées
sont accessible 7 jours sur 7
via le pass navigo sans oublier
l'atelier de réparation à disposition
cette nouvelle année verra l'avènement
d'un nouveau service vd go location une
flotte de vélos électriques proposés par
ile-de-france mobilité pour toujours
plus de circulation douce la mobilité se
passe aussi dans les airs mais que
devient le projet des navettes suspendu
le projet avance il sera présenté aux
élus je pense d'ici le mois de début
janvier nous espérons donc pouvoir
imposer le démonstrateur
mais les plus raisonnables au total
quatre ou cinq stations sont prévues
pour ces navettes autonome
imaginé par la start up the prize celles
ci pourront transporter jusqu'à sept
voyageurs sans conducteur elles
fonctionneront à l'énergie solaire et
électriques 7 jours sur 7 24 heures sur
le passager pourra commander sa navette
via son téléphone portable
le projet initial desservira les
communes de montigny-le-bretonneux
trappe et l'encours et plaisir les
stations seront implantées en gare de
saint quentin en yvelines au futur
polski high tech en passant par les
sites retenus pour accueillir les
épreuves de jeux olympiques et
paralympiques 2024
le troisième et dernier volet est celui
du logement le but est de répondre aux
besoins des habitants du territoire mais
aussi aux salariés nombreux qui vivent
en dehors de l'agglomération mais
viennent travailler chaque jour
certains chantiers se termine d'autres
débuteront en 2019
[Musique]
rencontre il ya un gros besoins en
logements sur saint quentin en yvelines
puisque on nous impose la production de
logements par an à 12 communes
ces dernières années l'agglomération a
retroussé ses manches depuis son premier
plan local de l'habitat en 2006 de
nombreux projets ont vu le jour à
travers une offre répondant à divers
publics salariés jeunes seniors familles
et des projets intergénérationnels
on a beaucoup de grands logements
familiaux sur saint quentin en yvelines
est donc aujourd'hui le besoin va des
verts des typologies plus petit et puis
aussi le besoin d'attirer de jeunes
salariés sur le territoire parce que il
y à une offre d'emploi très importante
sur saint quentin
mais ce qui peut être un frein c'est si
on peut pas se loger à proximité en
avril 2017 l'agglomération a signé un
contrat cadre
habitat emploie avec action logement
l'objectif étant de répondre aux besoins
des salariés en recherche de logement
le site vivront développé par la start
up et attract permet d'optimiser sa
recherche pour in fine et encourager le
rapprochement domicile travail sur les
diverses communes du territoire
les projets sortent de terre à
guyancourt avec la zac de villa roy a
trap avec la zac de l'aérostat à
maurepas au domaine d'iberville à
voisins le bretonneux dans le futur
quartier de la remise 500 logements sont
prévus ainsi que divers services 95
logements sont aussi à l'étude entre
voisins et montigny le bretonneux
après dans d'autres villes il ya
également le sujet de renouvellement
urbain
donc l'objectif de ces plans de
rénovation
en fait c'est de refaire un peu la ville
sur la ville d'assurer plus de mixité
dans le
dans les logements et selon les communes
éventuellement voilà faire tomber des
grands ensembles qui aujourd'hui n'ont
plus de sens mais pour reconstruire au
même au même endroit réaccueillir la
population qui souhaite bien sûr rester
non dans ces communes
pour nous l'enjeu c'est que saint
quentin en yvelines reste un territoire
tracklist est de continuer à développer
le concept d'innovation
vous savez désormais tout sur les grands
projets 2009 très bonne année à toutes
et à tous ciao
[Musique]